we're asked to adjust the angle and
radius of the orange
plotted complex number so that's this
right over here to match the blue
plotted complex number negative 3.5 plus
6.06 i
so this is this one right over here so
just to get our bearings this vertical
axis this is where this is the imaginary
axis this horizontal axis is the real
axis and so this is this the real part
of this number is negative 3.5 and so
we've plotted that on the real axis
negative 1 negative 2 negative 3.5 and
then the imaginary part is
6.06 so we go up 1 2 3 4 5 6 and then a
very little bit to get to 6.06 so
they've plotted it like that and now
they want us to think about it in kind
of the the the polar form is one way of
thinking about it
and so they tell us that we can adjust
the angle which is often called the
argument when you're plotting up
a complex number in this form and the
radius which is often called the modulus
so let's change that so let's see if we
increase the radius
so then the thing is going to go out a
little bit if we increase the angle
so angle that's pi over 3 this is pi
over 2 so we increase the angle to 2 pi
over 3 and this seems to be the right
direction and we just have to increase
the radius a little bit
so there we have a radius of seven an
angle of two thirds pi
now let's verify for ourselves that this
that this that this complex number and
this complex number really are the same
thing we've already seen it right over
here in this actual diagram we've
plotted it both in i guess you could say
rectangular form and polar form although
this is a complex axis and this is a
real axis so let me copy and paste the
information that we have here
so let me just copy and paste all of
that and then i can put it on my
little scratch pad
so let me throw it right over there and
let's actually verify that
let's very let's verify that
so here
we have an argument or an angle i guess
i could say of so this angle often
referred to as phi when you're dealing
in the complex plane this is equal to
two-thirds pi and this is of course in
radians and the modulus which is really
the distance from the origin to the
complex number this right over here
by just manipulating that little tool we
saw that to be 7. so let's verify that
this is really the same complex number
as negative 3.5 plus
6.06
i
well we can represent this as
7
the this is the modulus or the radius
seven times e to the two thirds pi i
two thirds pi i
which we know from euler's identity is
the exact same thing this is equal to
and this is one of really the most
mind-blowing things in all of
mathematics this is the same thing as
seven
times cosine
of two-thirds
pi
plus
i sine
of two thirds
pi and they already wrote that down for
us right over there now let's verify
what cosine of two-thirds pi is and what
sine of two-thirds pi is so if this is
two-thirds as an angle and now you can
almost even think of the unit circle
and if you were to take so this is
two-thirds pi
so actually let me just draw a unit
circle like this
because i don't want you just to confuse
just our traditional rectangular
coordinates with what we're doing on the
polar axis so this isn't the polar we're
not graphing polar chord we're not
graphing imaginary numbers right over
here we're just this is just a
traditional unit circle this is our
x-axis this is our y-axis two-thirds pi
is the same thing as 120 degrees so it
looks just like what we did over here so
two-thirds pi
so let me draw it as neatly as i can
which isn't that neatly so that angle is
two-thirds pi
our
cosine of two-thirds pi is going to be
our x-coordinate here is going to be our
x coordinate and sine of 2 3 pi is going
to be our y coordinate over here so
what's our x coordinate well this is 100
and if this right over here is 120
degrees then this is 60 degrees this is
a 30-60-90 triangle
and we know this is a unit circle the
radius is one so the 30-degree side will
have length one-half so this coordinate
right over here is going to be negative
one-half
negative one-half and then the six the
side opposite the 60 degree side is
square root of three times the one half
so this right over here is going to be
square root of three over two and you
could verify that on a calculator if you
like so cosine of two thirds pi is
negative one half so this is going to be
equal to
seven times negative one half that's
cosine of two thirds pi
plus i
times the square root of three
over two so let's verify that that's
actually the same thing as that over
there well seven times negative one-half
is negative 3.5
plus
i i'll just write it like 7 square root
of 3
over 2 i
so we already see that the real parts
are definitely the same it's negative
3.5 and i'll get a calculator out to
evaluate this and see if it is roughly
6.06
so get my trusty tti 85 out
and then
i want to evaluate 7 times the square
root of 3
and then that divided by 2
is indeed 6.06 if we round to the
nearest hundredths so this is
approximately equal to negative 3.5 plus
6.06 i which is exactly
the the complex number that we started
with